all right I hate that we have to do this
but once we've opened the door we have
to do it because people are actually
starting to follow this guy Bobby
Kennedy Jr held his completely unhinged
Health policy Roundtable yesterday I
told you look look at this screenshot I
told you about the Kooks that were part
of this round table including in the
lower left of the screen Dr Sherry 10
Penny that's the woman who said everyone
you know will be dead from the vaccine
soon
um and that it's a form of child abuse
and anyway she's nuts at the bottom
center Dr Joseph Mercola who's been
fined for the by the FDA for spreading
medical disinformation and some of the
products that he selling every single
one of these people I talked to you
about yesterday so Bobby Kennedy holds
this event these are the last people who
should be dictating or even weighing in
on health policy in the United States
and Bobby Kennedy comes up with another
Bonkers claim now saying that there is
good evidence that vaccine research is
actually responsible for the existence
of HIV the virus that causes AIDS RSV
Lyme disease and even the Spanish flu I
will tell you before even playing the
clip that this is not true but I'm going
to play it for you we're going to
discuss it these assertions that Bobby
Kennedy makes with absolutely no
hesitation or shame whatsoever are
incorrect and potentially dangerous
let's listen and you know we need
I will end all gain a function research
I will
I will sign a treaty on to end again a
function research for you know to get
all the nations
and get a function research it's just a
disaster it's it's given us no benefits
it's given us you know everything from
Lyme disease to covid and many many
other diseases that RSV which is now
that one of the biggest killers of
children
aim out of you know a a vaccine lab you
know so
uh and and we can go down a whole list
of diseases that you know down to and
there's good evidence that even Spanish
flu
came from Facts a vaccine a vaccine
research and you know we don't know and
we'll probably never know but the you
know they're very very strong articles
suggesting that now super strong
articles now it just so happens
everything that he said there is untrue
this just isn't true and you have you
know the these other vectors of medical
disinformation nodding along and none of
those things are true I mean HIV is a
virus that attacks the immune system it
can cause AIDS it's transmitted through
certain bodily fluids it was not caused
by vaccine research it originated from
zoonotic transmission of Simeon
immunodeficiency virus Simeon of course
referring to monkeys uh that that's HIV
it's not a result of vaccine research
RSV is a virus that causes respiratory
infections that can be particularly
serious in young kids I have friends who
have had kids in the hospital in icus
with RSV it's spread through droplets in
the air or on surfaces and it is not
caused by vaccine research it was not
created by vaccine research Lyme disease
Lyme is a bacterial infection not a
virus transmitted by ticks it can cause
rash fever fatigue headaches it can be
chronic
extensive scientific Studies have looked
at Lyme and its Origins are completely
unrelated to vaccine research they have
to do with ticks and and mice and there
is so much research online and then
Spanish Flu was indeed a pandemic caused
by a strain of H1N1 influenza A virus
flu okay infected about a third of the
world's population uh in the late 19
teens killed up to 50 million people the
exact number there are different
estimates but up to 50 million is a is a
good estimate and believed to have
originated from birds and spread through
human contact now by the way the Spanish
Flu
1918 not 1917 the way Trump says there
was not a flu vaccine at the time the
first flu vaccine was developed in the
30s and introduced in 1938 nearly 20
years after
um the Spanish flu so it this stuff just
isn't true and every time we talk about
it some people will write to me and
they'll say David this is so minor what
about Bobby Kennedy's views on Wars or
this or that
these beliefs and the willingness to
spread this stuff is uniquely
disqualifying when someone wants to be
president of the United States that it's
it's not a question of how much does
Bobby Kennedy want to talk about this
versus not versus other people talking
about it or forcing him to talk about it
or whatever these are uniquely
disqualifying views and by the way these
aren't the only concerning views that
Bobby Kennedy uh junior holds so uh
Health policy panel
even I told you it would be unhinged it
was even more unhinged than I expected
it to be and these are simply lies if
you or one of your parents is starting
to lose your hearing you're not alone
about 48 million Americans have hearing
loss and only one in five people who
would benefit from using a hearing aid
are actually using one our sponsors MD
hearing create FDA registered
rechargeable hearing aids that cost a
fraction of what you typically pay for
example MD hearings new Neo model costs
less than 10 percent of what those
marked up hearing aids are being sold
for at most hearing clinics and the Neo
is MD hearings smallest hearing aid ever
no one will even know that it's there I
have a close family friend who uses MD
hearing and loves it she said it
performs better than any hearing aid
that she's used and it's far less
noticeable MD hearing even offers a
45-day risk-free trial with a 100 sent
money back guarantee so you can buy with
confidence and they have a special deal
for my audience when you buy a pair of
hearing aids you'll get them for just
149.99 each plus they'll include a free
extra charging case go to mdhearing.com
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below